i feel like we just have that connection
now though like she gets it
like you guys don't even have to
practice yeah we're just like in sync
literally addison ray officially made
her reality tv debut
on keeping up with the kardashians and
on thursday's episode fans got a look
into the tick-tock star's close
friendship with kourtney kardashian
addison ray is a
world-renowned tick-tock
mason introduced me to knowing who she
was
addison and i made a hoosh workout video
together
and we've been working out ever since
and she just basically never left i mean
i feel
fine i just cry myself to sleep every
night yeah that's
totally normal courtney and i just
happened to have a great friendship
which is
really fun and she's been a great person
to have in my life
courtney and addison sport matching
outfits oh gypsies
oh my goodness we're disney princesses
wow you guys look nice
yeah the vibe for today was disney i
like
it disney princessy wow what are you
guys wearing
we just felt like matching wow have a
secret handshake
addison and i are learning uh a
handshake
like a like a friendship shape yeah like
when you see each other like with some
tick-tock moves involved
like oh my god it would only make sense
see that i love it and the pooch founder
and social media star
even have sleepovers which got kim and
chloe
questioning their 41 year old sister's
friendship with the
20 year old courtney's not really like
this with her other girlfriends
we just don't know courtney's a vault
she's always been like this
we're just nosey and gossipy and we want
to like gossip just with each other
so i want to investigate the
kardashian's close friend harry hudson
also questioned courtney and addison's
relationship
the real question is addison and
courtney
let's really talk about this oh my god
during a lunch with courtney's ex and
the father of her three children scott
disick
kris jenner kendall jenner kim and chloe
the fam grilled the tick tock star what
the [ __ ] do you do to courtney to make
her so happy
honestly at the beginning we were like
wait are they
i'm still thinking that hooking up
if it was like that kind of relationship
that was the elephant in the room if
they were
no we're not it's okay if you are no
we're not
nobody judges but it is funny no it's
just very weird
that that's what the impression was yeah
for just like two seconds i would say
like four
in the end kim and chloe did give their
stamp of approval
for courtney and addison's friendship i
actually really enjoy getting
to know addison and the more i get to
know her the more
i understand why court is such good
friends with her i think she's so
genuine i think she's so nice she's just
a good person and a good friend
when et spoke with addison in september
she opened up about the judgment about
the big age gap with courtney
i feel like friendships can range from
any age and
i feel like everyone can relate to
people in different ways and courtney
and i just happen to
have a great friendship which is really
fun and she's been a great
person to have in my life and um she she
said in my youtube video that
i had great energy that she liked to be
around but i think she has great energy
as well and she has so much experience
in her life that
um i can really just look at and kind of
learn from